[Music]
so what do you guys think is maybe one
of the worst things that could happen
during a funeral
a funeral
somebody dies wow true
another person dying yeah yeah but then
you get a two-for-one special right so
like i don't think we're gonna shove the
other body in the coffin it depends how
close they are just roll them into the
dirt
someone else falls into the grave that
would be bad like trips and falls yeah
that would be very bad it ends up being
the wrong body in the casket oh that
would be i bet that happens
someone hijacks the funeral by proposing
that's [ __ ] that's good that's a
tight idea though because you got
everyone there yep that's pretty messed
up good it's like those [ __ ] that
hijack a wedding with their their
proposals love those guys you know
everyone i'd like to make an
announcement oh my god it's like
[ __ ] it's their wedding why do
you do that oh we were in the spirit of
love man isn't it good our family and
friends are here
everyone's here already
steve stands up he's yeah why haven't we
seen that in a movie or something anyone
else
we talked about that recently in a jk
article because there was somebody who's
doing that yeah i feel like it's like a
movie cliche like people get excited
like they get married and then
afterwards you see a proposal and [ __ ]
dude if you want everyone the
bridesmaids start talking [ __ ] on you
just do that
they'll immediately start [ __ ]
talking all kinds of [ __ ] okay so a
massachusetts family whose loved one's
casket fell open that was being lo as it
was being lowered into a grave causing
the body to fall out has sued the
funeral home in the cemetery
that's pretty much the worst thing that
guy the rest so it was it was lowering
and then just
and then like
problem
rolling eyes are open and then the body
just [ __ ] dropped yeah like what
happens to the body does it stay stiff
or does it like unreal engines the whole
way down and the eyes are open casket
fall onto them too oh
and they also tried to cut corners and
then put pants on them the bottom half
that's the best
if there were no fancy just all my
caskets are just like oh we're good the
front the front of the pants
it's lower bear like we do have to ask
if you like to say 50 by not having
pants
pump pants at a front shirt no pants no
shoes it's just fronts
that's so embarrassing
nothing but ass cheeks the naked bag
assless chaps
burial suit
oh
oh [ __ ] that's dope yeah so one of the
side straps to the city owned casket
lowering device broke causing the casket
to fall into the grave and break apart
oh the corpse quote fell out of the
casket in full view of the horrified
family members who became visibly
distraught and even hysterical
wait so how high was the coffin at the
time if everyone saw it was like high up
in them
higher than usual just so you just see a
body like high enough i think it was
high enough yeah what the [ __ ] that's
mortifying like literally yes mortified
i don't think i've ever seen a casket
get lowered into a grave like i've been
to funerals all that stuff yeah but i've
never seen it being like it's usually
just in like a suspended like it's like
a bunch of cables and it just goes like
that much yeah yeah it's not like a
construction site where they're like
moving somewhere they're lowering them
just slowly it's like they're installing
a fish tank
samuel lobster tank
what are they in boys
it's clear coffin on the bottom so you
can see the ass
[Laughter]
is that the new move like a glass bottom
boat
i'm sure i'm sure there's options out
there for like clear coffins
oh yeah yeah definitely there's all
kinds of weirdos out there sure i think
the first person to do that was sleeping
beauty or some [ __ ] like
glass coffin yeah have you guys seen
michael jackson's mausoleum no
[ __ ] crazy dude i'll hold it up it's
actually crazy i kind of want a
mausoleum when i'm dead even if that's
when you know you're balling huh yeah
cause those are a lot aren't they a
studio apartment
mine can be made out of wood this is why
you just kind of burn people dude you
just want the mausoleum definition but
not any of the what's that mausoleum i
expected that like a cabin it's like
next to the groundskeeper's hut i want a
[ __ ] mausoleum with a statue dude i
want to i just want the qr code
tombstone
oh yeah those are pretty cool so then
like when you when you uh click the link
it just goes please solve the mystery of
my death
like
i act like it was like this big murder
mystery it's just like a a hologram of
you comes out just your face it's just
like you're looking at this i died
avenge me it's just all repeat your
tombstone goes viral
the true crime community is just like
we're going to rally together
an innocent person goes to jail
i can't tell you who killed me but here
are 12 clues
one to be released every year
i don't even know this guy dude you
could sell your clues as nfts
people to figure out who killed you dude
the clues would be so expensive
apparently this is where michael jackson
is buried and like this is that a church
the sun hits it hits the thing at a
certain time
and you can visit wow no you can't you
can't go in you can just see it from
outside i guess and that was the photo
they chose to take
this is just the one one that i can find
there's a lot of places that say they
don't know where michael jackson is
what yeah i know
kind of making me think he's made me
alive
i for sure want a sick ass mausoleum
metaverse mausoleum oh maybe i could
afford a metaverse mausoleum that'll be
crazy how much do you think they would
go for what if you could still be alive
in the metaverse that's what i'm saying
like you can be alive in the metaverse
as like a bot so your family can visit
you yeah the fact that there's a
metaverse and you still want to be dead
in it
he's like maybe you could get a medal
for some mausoleum like you can also not
die
imagine you could download your brain
though dude wouldn't that be interesting
ah dude it's like altered carbon
remember that [ __ ] on netflix oh yeah
you'll be choreographing pieces that's
the metaverse right there
you could be [ __ ] you could be black
today tomorrow you could be asian you
could be a woman you could be anything
imagine all the unremarkable brains that
will get saved in the near future
unremarkable [ __ ] wasteful dude right
it's like if a philosopher is like
hundreds of years from now talking to us
imagine that [ __ ] yeah
like shut up there's gonna be like a
futurama where the heads of like old
like leaders are in those uh chambers
except we say nothing interesting
we're like yeah i don't know
i would think by a thousand years though
those idiots would probably become smart
because they'll have a lot of time to
get it together that's what i'm thinking
i'm hoping i'm hoping our kids are smart
guys all right i doubt it if they could
extend their brain yeah we bring back an
old philosopher into the metaverse
they're like what the [ __ ] is this
i can't process any of it newton's like
this is not my law
this is [ __ ] you're probably our
graphics will suck compared to theirs
too oh yeah argumentative reverse
graphics gonna suck compared to the next
generations the next generation is just
gonna be like reality yeah exactly where
you can't tell the difference between
reality yeah finally it's about to
happen dude we're like this close
because you know have you heard of the
simulation theory where we are the
metaverse for like another being i love
that [ __ ] because the odds are so small
that this is the real world it just
sounds like religion like buddhism or
whatever just like reincarnation well
you've heard that like in like minecraft
you can build games and [ __ ] because
there's like all these weird mechanisms
in minecraft it's like in that game you
can build games it's like it's like how
we build games in our world the same
thing yeah it's just everything there is
like pixelated dude everything's gonna
get so [ __ ] crazy no more i'm kind of
just not ready for it but when you think
of like ready player one you're like all
right this is gonna be pretty cool but
that's gonna be a whole [ __ ] is it
that you said that's what metaverse is
trying to do right
i think that's the um
fantastical dream that everybody's
hoping for right now end result yeah i
think that to get there they've
mentioned already it's going to take a
long time and a lot of like an economy
first house
has to also be established for like
developers and stuff like that to like
want to continue to pour in that much
like this this is web 3.0 this is
literally the next frontier of like the
internet age and stuff like that so like
to do it and build it out the right way
is it's going to take so much time but
like we'll be dead by then i don't think
we'll i think it'll be a decade or eight
years
i mean you do live hard you live hard
i feel like you're built to survive
you'll be alone
i just hope bitcoin pumps before the
metaverse comes out yeah it will be fine
i think digital funerals though and
weddings in the metaverse like to bring
back to this are actually getting pretty
sick right imagine like oh here's
regular use case right uh
asian relative or some [ __ ] that's in
asia can't make it to your wedding
funeral clocks in via digital
holographic ar can participate i mean
maybe not steve green and his brother
[ __ ] rolling around and started
shooting [ __ ] hey look if they if they
leave that exploit open i'm going to
[ __ ] exploit it you know i'm saying
people like
digitally or hologram
wise via ar can like be somewhere that
they normally wouldn't be able to you
know what i'm saying the live event and
i think that's like the first step
but obviously
going into the the imagination like what
else can you do what else can you be a
part of in that digital space you know
what i mean and use to your advantage
like damn of course i'm excited for that
[ __ ] i never want to go to a funeral
anyway steve's gonna be at the better
version you're gonna be like hello just
the gravedigger passing by don't mind me
very much everybody enjoy the funeral
and enjoy the funeral joy out of out of
nowhere a [ __ ] bulldozer comes
oh yeah dude scooping the [ __ ] ground
up digging holes all around the [ __ ]
casket
the biggest [ __ ] hole didn't [ __ ]
kanye send kim kardashian like a video
of her father yeah a good hologram
hologram of robert
bob kardashian and it was so weird
because he had like a whole script that
he would that whoever like acted out the
part of robert kardashian had to read
off it was just praising kanye as like a
great guy during a certain section
so like you know kanye [ __ ] wrote is
like you got a great husband kanye a
genius great man yeah
amazing father this is a genius idea oh
god so back to your birthday
so we got we gotta bust like a tony
stark right and do that [ __ ] like when
we die as well like pre-recorded
messages to our like a future children's
[ __ ] right there oh yeah but
unremarkable things yeah
insults or just plagiarize it just i
love you three thousand
[Laughter]
well i think it's gonna be cool dude
gathering with family members is gonna
be the first thing that will be like the
littest thing ever it'll be hard to like
bail oh true before you could use
traffic as an excuse you could use i'm
sick as you know so many you'll just
start phasing out your camera you're
pretending like all the connections
just turn your vpn on
ah sorry i don't know what happens
they're gonna make jury duty like
metaverse oh first [ __ ] dude oh my gosh
don't even joke about it's gonna suck
i'm down for jury duty in the metaverse
this might be harder to dodge can you
imagine all the people are gonna be gay
they're gonna be caught jacking off
huh yeah oh yeah
that's going to happen well it already
happened during covet there was a lot of
jerk off accidentally jerk off videos
yeah all the zoos what do you mean
oopsie oh like guys are like okay guys
uh good meeting today bob and i'll see
you guys tomorrow all right thank you
oh yeah it's time to jerk it
jerky so literally
they announced it too i am about to come
all over my computer
i've been waiting for this
it's an old guy isn't it oh yeah oh yeah
time for my next meeting
[Laughter]
hello secretary dude yeah that happened
a ton with like really important people
too just stop jerking off after a zoom
you can't wait like five minutes can't
we wait five minutes just five minutes
dude can't even close the tab
dude i'll show up to jury dude i'm like
hello everybody don't mind me just a
gravedigger
not here to jury duty nope nope gotta
dig some graves he's like notorious for
being on every meta versus there's a
[ __ ] guy again he's just here to dig
some graves [ __ ] the grave dirt is gonna
ruin it
[Music]
you